in this episode i interviewed two
professors dr david sabral and dr
avi loeb this is a new format of episode
i've named
complementary views astrophysics and
alien tech for this episode
it's an episode like opposing views
except the views are not opposing they
complement each other
the first section of this episode
features dr david sobral a professor at
lancaster university who gives us a
brief background on astrophysics
so we can better understand the second
section from dr avi loeb
professor at harvard university and now
best-selling author
who gives information on what he
believes was alien tech that passed by
earth
let me know what you think of this kind
of format of episode remember to hit
subscribe if you want to see more
this episode is made possible by hover a
domain name vendor
something that makes hover special is it
has a ton of options for different
endings on domains
it has over 300 domain name extensions
to choose from when building your brand
online
no matter what you want to build there's
a domain name waiting for it
you can end your website in blog or dot
diet or whatever instead of
com if you so choose i use hover for
that reason i
actually just bought mp.show check them
out at hover.com
mp and get a 10 discount with that
referral link on all new purchases
hover.com mp also linked below let me
know what you think about this kind of
episode i really enjoyed it
[Music]
dr david sabrel welcome to my podcast
it's really good to be here thank you
i've been
excited about this podcast for a while
because i've been interested in this and
i think everybody is to a degree
because it's so foreign but let's start
off
could you give a brief background to my
audience about who you are and what it
is that you do
so my my name is david sabraw i'm an
extra galactic astrophysicist
and i think the best way of putting it
is that i i use
some of the largest telescopes to go
back in time
so it's pretty cool wow
that is cool okay can we start off this
is going to be
this is an intro to astrophysics so i'm
going to ask if anyone
listening is already into astrophysics
this might be a little bit beginner
but let's start off with what is what is
astrophysics
i mean to put it very simply you can
think of the planet earth
and then anything beyond your disaster
physics and astronomy
so it means we can study anything beyond
our own planet
and that will include stars other
planets
dust gas and even like weird things like
dark matter and dark energy
okay you said you said something about
going back in time so can you
can you describe uh just in simplified
terms what is
what what is time gravity and space
oh that's a it's a good good very uh
complete
question in terms of going back in time
i guess perhaps the easiest way
is that it's actually it's not
instantaneous anything that you say will
take
maybe a split of a second to get to me
on this side of the pond
right and you can think of if distances
are so so large
anything you say will take sometimes
years
sometimes millions of years sometimes
billions of years to actually get there
so imagine that you're broadcasting this
podcast to aliens
and it means that it will be heard about
in about a year if they are listening
one light year away
so what i do is i find things that are
so so far away
that the information took billions of
years to get to us
so when we get that information we can
actually know how things look like in
the past
so it's really all about how long the
information takes
and if you find super distant things
then you are
going back in time okay okay that makes
sense this is going to be a good
conversation i actually understood that
okay um gravity gravity for dummies
gravity for dummies uh well i guess you
learn it as a kid
right that uh you know if you drop
something it will fall uh or if you lose
your equilibrium you will also fall
essentially there's a
there's a pull from the earth that's the
simplest way of
portraying gravity perhaps the most
advanced
way of understanding gravity is that
it's actually
not a force but it's more like whenever
there is a mass
it actually bends things around it and
it
it sort of makes space-time have a slope
and you can
yeah okay yeah that we need to get into
that a little bit because i don't
understand how
time or space but i don't understand how
time can have a slope what does that
mean
i mean well i guess it's hard to
comprehend in three dimensions
uh the easiest way is if you think of a
something like a sheet of paper
or something made of rubber right you
can understand that if you if you make a
ball
if you put a ball on on top of it it
will bend
and essentially what happens is and in
space-time
around our earth space-time becomes
blended because of the presence of mass
i mean it's just something to do with
the universe it's just something that
happens whenever there's mass
then space time around it gets a little
bit bended
and if okay if you're really massive it
bends a lot
if we're not so massive it only bends a
little bit
but what we perceive as gravity
essentially we we're attracted to the
earth
but in reality this happens because
space-time around the earth is bended so
we're like
going down a slope and we can't help it
we can't help but fall
okay i did not know that that's
interesting i was going to say what
difference like what
what is a slope to us what why does that
matter and you're saying the slope
is gravity so gravity is
yes so it's us experiencing the presence
of a slope
will make it look like a force i mean
because we can't help but but go down
right if
if you sit on a slope you will just go
down unless there's a lot of friction
and and gravity this is how it works
this is the reason why the earth can't
help but orbit the sun
because it the earth is trying to move
away and then space-time is bended so
it's
it's continuously kind of falling into
the sun
and then moving a little bit away same
thing for satellites
okay okay so just back up a little bit
what do you mean by space
uh i guess you could just think it in
spaces in
the you know the material 3d
framework in which we live we move we
can go up
down left right okay so distance kind of
so yeah i mean i guess distance only
exists within space
that's true and to our perception
space has three dimensions right like
again could go up down
left right the reason why it gets a
little bit more complicated to picture
this spending
one of the reasons is because it's
space-time itself that bends
so in a way it's like there's four
dimensions
even though we're we're typically only
perceiving three
okay how did people figure out that this
exists
i guess because of the work of a lot of
different people and especially
albert einstein is one of the people
that
really led to this notion that gravity
is actually not a force
but it's a bending in space time
that's insane yeah that's very cool okay
okay
i think there's like a limit to my
understanding there so let's continue
uh what's the what's the difference
between a comet and an asteroid
so um the easiest way to explain is
that something can become essentially
the comet will need to have a tail
typically comets have like uh really
eccentric orbits
they take a long time and typically they
get really close to the sun
and then they go really far away and
the reason why sometimes we can see it
on the sky like that
beautiful tail is because when comets
get really close to the sun
they eat up and they're typically made
of ice
and other material that starts exploding
and
and essentially we can see the tail of
dust and sometimes even
water essentially evaporating and
asteroids
typically something that does not do
that
so typically a body that will be in a
more circular orbit
more stable so it never gets too too
close to the sun
to burn and it never gets too far away
to
to completely get iced so it's
okay quickly bodies they're much more
common orbits like like the earth
okay so just to reiterate does that mean
they're basically
other than where they go um they're kind
of the same
so they can be made of the same exactly
so okay
you could always i mean if you're
incredibly rich and you have a
spacecraft
you can just go and get an asteroid if
you could get out of the orbit
making you could transform it into a
comet at least many of them
provided you have you have the material
such as ice and gas to then
do that amazing tale okay i've heard
something
i think it's called asteroid mining
maybe or some term thrown around so what
is that what does that mean
so that's the idea that at least in some
future
we'll be able to send some spacecraft
and robots and mine asteroids
because they will be they are rich in
heavy elements
you know some of them will have gold and
silver
or just other materials to build stuff
on earth yeah
cool okay what what is a black hole
a black hole uh simplest way of putting
it
is a point in space where there was so
much mass that
space time that we were talking about
that bends right whenever there's a mass
it's so bended that it's kind of um it
got destroyed essentially a hole
essentially you could you can think of
the rubber being so so
so so stretched at some point it breaks
it actually
is a hole and this means that if you get
close enough
you will feel the slope and you will
actually
essentially get into that hole which you
will never be able to get out
and this is okay perhaps the geometric
way of looking at it
the simplest way is a black hole is
something that if you go in
you can never get out that's the
simplest way of putting it
okay and i thought it wasn't it's it's
not an actual
i thought this could be wrong though but
i thought it was something that had
such intense gravity that you kind of
got sucked into nothing
but it wasn't a hole leading somewhere
right
i guess i mean the question whether
leads somewhere or not
uh is beyond the scope of the things we
could do um
but it is sort of a hole in space time
as far as we perceive it
in in the sense that if you get there
there's no way of coming back
and is it is indeed gravity is so strong
that you need to be moving faster than
light to get out that's that's
the fundamental difficulty of escaping
so
doesn't that mean i mean so these black
holes exist
all over they might exist all over and
they're formed typically out of the most
massive star so the sun will not
transform into a black hole
so we're so that ends okay and even if
the sun transformed into a black hole
i mean it would be bad because there
would be no sun but everything would
keep
moving around the sun as if nothing
happened
because as long as you don't get too
close then black holes are actually
you know they're not that bad okay okay
but most black holes will form out of
the death of
the most massive stars so stars are way
way bigger than the sun
when they finish their lives they go
supernova
it's actually really important because
they're the reason why we can breed
oxygen
so every single oxygen atom that you're
breeding right now was once part of a
supernova
every single one of them that's that's
really cool wow
what is left behind is a black hole
okay gives you some cosmic perspective
of uh the things you had
oh wow i didn't know that at all yeah
and it's every single one of them i mean
it's
it's quite remarkable every single
oxygen atom was once part of an
explosion
of a massive star before it turned into
something like a black hole
wow okay so you can have a black hole
and as long as you're far enough
if you're far enough away then things
would just orbit it right
rather than getting sucked into it
exactly
yes so the problem is if you get too
close or if you're moving straight into
the black hole that's that's really hard
provided you're sort of an attendant or
you then
you don't get too close then you're
you're sort of okay
okay and this bending in space and time
was that i really don't know anything
about this was that figured out because
planets orbit and don't just fall into
the sun it was figured out
one of the reasons actually was the
orbit of mercury
so mercury is the closest to the sun and
it actually
orbits in a weird way so the the normal
notion of gravity being a force would
not be able to explain it
and this was one of the reasons why
einstein pursued this idea
and it turns out that if if gravity is
the bending of space-time then then we
can understand exactly why mercury
does that so it's to do with when you
get very close to a star
then the gravity force is a bit
different if it's an actual force versus
being the
space-time bend that's the simplest way
you could
okay okay that that vaguely makes sense
that's that's incredible okay um dark
matter
what's dark matter uh i mean if you if
you knew out i'm sure you'd get a nobel
prize
so that's the that's the first thing
we kind of know how it works we have no
idea what it's made of there are some
hypotheses some candidates but it's it's
basically
a statement of our ignorance when it
comes to looking up
and understanding that we see for
example space-time being bent
in certain ways but then there's nothing
there or there's not enough to bend
space
in that way so that was
first seen for example around galaxies
which are these big structures of
hundreds
hundreds of billions of stars and we
realized that space-time was bent around
them
in a way that stars and gas and
everything else
could not explain and then
we also see evidence of that even on
larger scales
i guess the easiest way of saying it is
we can see the effects of gravity
but then there's not enough things
that we can see
okay is it possible is it possible
that you see this bend around galaxies
because of
the amount of i don't know i guess
gravity
in the entire galaxy like if you just
zoomed your perspective out and looked
at it as a whole
or people really explored all
possibilities of for example
sure they did yes yeah yeah but i mean
many people were skeptical and actually
to this day
there's many people that still are
skeptical of the existence of dark
matter
and the hypothesis that they have is
that instead
einstein was wrong in its depiction of
gravity
so the other alternative the alternative
to dark matter would be to say that
even though we got better at saying
gravity's space-time bending
maybe that's not enough and because
well clearly we can't identify what's
bending space-time
but that's sort of a minority of i guess
scientists are pursuing this
okay so most people think dark matter is
just something that we just
can't see or can't identify yet
i think for me perhaps the most selling
or compelling
argument is the fact that uh so people
can actually put all the ingredients of
the universe
together it's pretty cool and and like
run it in a super computer
it's like baking cakes but you're baking
a universe right
and then at the end i think it's it's
pretty cool because
if you don't put dark matter into the
recipe
it's basically you never get a cake or
in other words
if you don't put dark matter when you're
making a fake universe it never looks
anything like our own it means that we
would never be able to exist
if you don't put it into the recipe dark
matter
it turns out how would you how would you
add dark matter into a recipe if you
don't know what it is is it just like
x that that's i mean excellent question
um
what uh actually ends up happening is
that even though we don't know what it
is
i mean technically it's a bit weird but
we know more of how it behaves
than the things that make us because as
far as we can tell
dark matter only cares about gravity it
ignores everything else
like i don't know you're putting the
your finger in a plug
dark matter doesn't care it will not be
shocked or
magnets it doesn't care either so in a
way it's the simplest way to model and
to put into a computer simulation
because it's just space-time bending
nothing else
okay what's a wormhole
um i guess so a
wormhole would be it's sort of
theoretical
no one has ever found one yeah okay
technically
uh maybe i need to explain more visually
so you can think of this as space-time
right think of this and uh we can think
of ourselves as maybe
creatures that exist uh within this
space-time is that okay yeah
vaguely yes you can think of ourselves
as some ants they are moving around
okay yes now what might happen is
there's no reason for this to be flat
like this so space time can have some
curvatures
and in principle if you exist within
this sheet of paper
it's really cheap uh i'm sure i could do
better
you can think of going from one side to
the other
right and if you were to do that
you'd probably think you need to cross
the entire sheet of paper right you're
you're a creature that only exists here
but if
if space-time is bent like this
you would still think that the way to go
is to go all the way around
but a wormhole is something
in principle where there is a hole
here where you could go directly
to the other side of the universe
without breaking any laws of physics
so in a way uh it if space-time is
is curved and bent in some way
it is possible that we're sort of close
to another side of the universe
and the wormhole is the passage to the
other side
of the universe and it's very
it's very theoretical because it would
require space time to be banned in just
the right way so that you could
you can like um get a hole and
and and go to somewhere very very far
away
and then we'd have to find it as well
yes yeah or create it i guess in the
maybe in the future will be so good that
um we would be able to create one of
these
oh my god that's terrifying yeah well
you look excited by that and i'm like
that seems like a bad thing to leave in
humans hands
but yeah i guess the the only good thing
about it
potentially is that um at least in
theoretical
modeling it will close very quickly so
it will require
a lot of expert knowledge to keep it
open so it is very unlikely that it
would go
into the wrong hands um i guess because
you would require
absolutely expert knowledge which
typically stored in better hands
hopefully yeah or just send some sucker
through it we'll keep it open don't
worry
uh okay how much how much do you need to
know about quantum physics
first what is quantum physics i know and
how much do you need to know of that in
order to understand
you know what you teach astrophysics i
think you don't need
to know actual quantum physics in terms
of the maths
and and i think a lot of the quantum
physics aspects can be described
relatively
simply it's just that the you know the
actual
quantification to do with maths are a
bit more complicated
and i think one of the coolest aspects
of
i guess quantum physics is the fact that
it is because of quantum physics that
the sun shines
and this is not something that we we
would know um
but this is it's mostly because so the
sun is really hot
it's producing energy all the time and
the reason for this is because
at the core of the sun there's some
protons
essentially you know tiny little
particles of positive charge
that naturally would repel i mean if you
try to put a
magnets built with positives they will
they'll go away
and within the sun the sun somehow
manages to get those two positive things
crushed into one and it produces a
heavier element
and that releases a lot of energy this
is how the sun
actually gets its energy out it's what
we call fusion
and that people are trying to do it on
earth to solve like the energy crisis
now the thing about quantum mechanics is
it's the reason why the sun can actually
get one of the protons to actually get
close enough to the other to fuse
and it's through a process that's really
spooky which is called quantum tunneling
and perhaps one of the coolest things in
quantum mechanics is that you can have a
wall
and the particle can actually go through
the wall
and this is possible and okay what is
okay quantum physics is it's cool
absolutely fascinating
i took like i briefly took science in
school and i took you know like the
first couple of years of physics and it
was
already fairly difficult but getting
down to those really small i never went
like did any research about space but
getting down to
even just chemical reactions or protons
and electrons that was very very very
interesting
um but impossible for me to understand
or to like grasp i was like i kind of
get it i kind of see the math but i just
don't understand
there's of course different aspects i
mean the more philosophical
and interpretational side i think can be
explained even without any math
but it i guess it takes some
understanding to then do it right to
simplify it in a way that's still
correct
without actually requiring all the
amounts um
but it's mostly to do with the fact that
at the very very small scales
you know particles are no longer balls
that's basically it it's just because
they you start to reveal their
um wave nature and waves
do things differently from particles
right it says
for example right now i mean i have some
wireless signal
going through the walls and no one
spooked about that
so it's just that in the quantum world
those kind of things become possible
even for you know actual particles they
can go through walls as if they are
waves
there are some people in tin hats that
are definitely spooked about that
but it's cool because it keeps us alive
that's uh it's a good practical
application
it keeps the sun essentially fusing
hydrogen into helium
and uh it gives us the heat that we need
to to stay alive
what's the um
i don't know if it was in theory or not
but it's
you have i think it's two electrons or
something
or two particles of some sort in two
different
places um and they should be
like wow this is this is like how i type
things into google i'm like please help
me google and
help me understand what i'm trying to
say but one ax can act like a wave and
one can act not like a wave but it can
happen at the same time do you have any
idea what i'm talking about
i think so i think you're talking about
it's a famous yeah one thing is
quantum entanglement okay there we go
which is
pretty cool and people have now
demonstrated and i guess some people are
exploring it as ways of like
communicating almost instantly
so it's as if two electrons are kind of
matched and so
yeah that that is what okay quantum
entanglement
yeah so if something happens to one then
the other one reacts
even though there's no time for the
information to to actually go there so
that is
i think even more spooky than things
going through the walls
and the other thing that you were
talking about is in quantum mechanics
everything is both a particle and a wave
at the same time
so there's just there's no helping
nature this is how things
are so that's a wave that's also a
particle at the same time
back to let's go back to quantum
entanglement that's the thing that's
that
is spooky so they've actually
demonstrated this
to be true and uh so i think one of the
first ones were even in um
two places in the canary islands and i
think they've now done it almost across
the earth
so like in labs they are further apart
by
thousands of kilometers and are they
looking at drink
are they looking at electrons what are
they looking at i'm not sure whether it
was
electrons but i think electrons are the
easiest one of the easiest things to to
do
yes and it's to do with the sp it's to
do with like one of the properties of
the
the electron that can be i guess you
could
get quantum entanglement to work and
then you you pull them apart
and they will still react as if they are
connected
it's the simplest way okay so they have
to be together first and then you do
something
something to them and take them okay
so he can't be just i don't know two
random electrons and something that
makes me feel a little bit better
yeah so it needs to be a carefully
conducting experiment
and it's kind of on like one to one
thing it's not like you can
entangle big things to other big things
okay wow that's fascinating do you have
any do you buy i know that you're a
astrophysics guy but do you have any
idea what they do
to electrons to get them to entangle i'm
not sure exactly the practicalities of
it
but it's just to do with their like the
quantum
mechanical state of
typically they cannot be occupying exact
same
place and have the exact same properties
so if you put them together they they
kind of naturally distribute in a way
that so that they can exist there
together
and i think it's just to do with with
how you do that and then by putting them
apart if you flip one the other one will
react
but this is definitely not something
that i know anyone could do
you need like a proper proper lab to to
to do it that's so wild
yeah okay okay that was very interesting
thank you you're good at explaining this
it's not like
you're good at simplifying it i know
sometimes you have professors and
they've been studying one thing for so
long that they kind of forget
what it's like not to understand at all
so you're good at this
uh what for if you wanted to study
something like astrophysics what's your
what does that look like education wise
is a lot of math
is it philosophy is it physics like
how many years does this take
i think there's quite a lot of different
paths um
myself i actually was considering on
studying literature
before i went into astronomy and
astrophysics there's people that
come at it from a more mathematical
point of view
and more like physics heavy others are
more interested because of like the oh
of
just looking up right like trying to
find our cosmic origins
so i think there's there's room for
everyone and i think one of the most
fascinating things is when you get
people with different perspectives right
in the same room
this is where the best ideas come about
if it's just people focused on the maths
typically you never get anywhere because
everyone's more focused on the formalism
instead of like the philosophical
implications and
in terms of the the paths i guess
studying anything related to physics
will involve some maths but in a way
some areas in astronomy will not be very
much heavy
especially if it's more observations so
it may be more like data analysis
sometimes a little bit more coding but a
lot of careers involve for example
outreach right like
telling people about how amazing the
discoveries are and
for example you know the the oxygen that
we breed was made in stars right it
makes us connect
to the cosmos in a way that perhaps we
weren't aware of
yeah yeah and it's important because you
know why should people
care there are a lot of problems on
earth right so you get people saying
well why are we focused on
why are we focused on studying what's
out there when we have problems down
here
but i think it gives us yeah really
important perspective
i mean one of the the big things i i do
with my students in the class i teach in
astronomy
is to understand how astronomy makes us
humble and i think that's so important
right to understand our cosmic
insignificance
and so one of the things they have to do
in the class
is to calculate how insignificant they
are and basically
that's amazing because this gives us the
perfect the perspective
of you know how small you are and it
turns out to be something like
we are a one a number one and a number
made of 85
84 zeros so if anyone
watching your podcast wants to write a
number with 84 zeros
and then we can write one and we are one
in that huge number
so it really gives us the humble
perspective
um yeah that's wild
uh okay do i have any more i think those
were the
oh okay one more and then i'll i'll let
you go
um is is there such thing as a
multiverse or is that a theory
it's a theory and in principle it may be
maybe possible that there are other
universes
and it's a it's perhaps quite an elegant
way of explaining why we're here
and perhaps going back to like uh uh
baking
universes or baking fake universes you
can think of different recipes
and there's no reason why the universe
knew exactly which cake to make
to get this here and so the fact that
we're here it means
a lot of the properties were just right
you know there was
the uh right amount of dark matter
stars formed in the same a given way
galaxies also evolved
to allow us to be here and the
multiverse
hypothesis would say that actually other
universes were created but they would
not have life to
you know question about why the universe
was so right for them
so it is a theoretical kind of uh
explanation it is a possibility but it's
not something that we know for sure
exists
think that answers i think that was
enough information for me for for the
last half hour um
where where can where can people find
you online do you have an online
presence
yeah i have like a very small youtube
channel where i try to do some some
outreach
um a very non-professional uh like talk
show that i did for
for a couple of months mostly for people
interested
um and what's that at so that's uh
youtube.com
that's where they can find there's some
of my teaching because it's being done
online so i tried to use my
my whiteboard to do demonstrations of
stuff it's a good idea bricks
so students are liking it quite a lot
yeah and there's my website xgil.uk
where i also have like um activities
that i develop for kids and adults
so they can use my data to make their
own discoveries
cool like finding the the brightest
galaxy
in the early universe that i found that
uh i called cr7
so they could use the actual data from
hubble and other telescopes and
and find it themselves with very simple
instructions actually
oh that is awesome okay can you spell
that website
it's x gal so x a
l dot uk it's very simple there's plenty
of resources but one of the things is
the
excalido yourself diy where you can use
you can use the real data to do it
that's very cool
okay and then this is my last question
then why do you
why why did you name it cr7
uh it's to do with the the coordinates
on the sky
okay it was discovered with um it's in
the field that's called cosmos and
the distance in astronomy is measured as
a redshift so that's where the r7 comes
from
but it was also uh to do with the
football player
ronaldo because i was also i'm
portuguese i was in lisbon at the time
and there was a a lot of things that we
we tried
and naming it cr7 was actually crucial
to get to people all over the world
so that's oh yeah so bbc smart
cnn were interviewing me for for the
discovery because
of the relation with the with the player
but it's i mean
one of the big reasons scientifically is
um
the galaxy uh probably contained
kind of evidence for the very first
stars that ever existed in the universe
so it was a big thing
essentially the stars that created the
first heavy elements
and so apart from being super bright and
super cool and then the name
it was because it had evidence of the
presence of these
first generation stars um so yeah
it was it was pretty cool it was it was
a good name because
that is a good name yeah yeah that's
very clever
people should do that so it's the galaxy
on the mug
as well yeah cool wow okay well thank
you very much that was really
interesting
thanks for giving me the questions
[Music]
dr abby loeb welcome to my podcast
thanks for having me
i am so excited about this i reached out
a number of months ago because i'd read
an article about you in new york
something new york post maybe i'm not
sure
this storm of media storm i would call
it
uh i i should tell you a an anecdote
that
uh before the new york post there was a
a podcast scheduled with joe organ that
my
literary agent organized and she she
told me it will be three hours
so you should eat a good breakfast
before that because it you know it will
probably exhaust you
little she knew that i had i would have
a marathon
of eight weeks not three hours
uh after the new york post article that
was back to back interviews
i would say of order 250 by now wow
that's incredible okay so joe rogan did
get to you first
i reached out pretty fast after the new
york post then
i got sent your book and i started
reading the book and thought
okay no i need i need way more time to
prepare for this because that book is
complicated and i have no background in
physics and was like
sorry i need to delay this a little bit
and read some more and then i saw a
whole onslaught of podcasts featuring
you and i was like
should have just done the podcast but
we're doing it now and at least i'm
prepared so i'm happy about that
can we start off by you giving a brief
background about who you are and what it
is that you do
sure um by the way i also didn't know
much physics
as a kid you know growing up on a farm
uh
and i didn't intend to pursue physics so
i very much sympathize with you and then
i'm you know it's the circumstances that
brought me to physics
so i was born in a village in israel and
they
collected eggs every afternoon and they
used to drive the tractor to the hills
of the village
on a week on weekends to read the
philosophy books i was
fascinated by the deep philosophical
questions about our life
and um and i i
plan to pursue philosophy as an adult
but then in israel you have to serve in
the military at age 18 and so
i had two options either to run in the
field with
a gun attached to me or actually do some
intellectual work
which i could pursue in the context of
physics
because physics is useful for the
defense of the country so
i was recruited to a program that
selects
20 to 30 young recruits
every year uh to finish a first degree
in physics and mathematics and then
apply it to projects that are
potentially of use
for national security and i was
fortunate to even finish my phd at age
24
during that program and the thing i
worked on was a project that
was funded by star wars the initiative
of
ronald reagan in the mid 1980s and
and that was the first international
project that was funded
uh i remember the visit of general
abramson that came to israel and
we presented the project and he liked it
a lot and that brought me to washington
quite frequently and then in one of the
visits i
went to see princeton uh the institute
for advanced study and
was introduced to freeman dyson who said
oh you are from israel let me introduce
you to someone who is married to an
israeli
john bakal and fortunately john was
around
he asked me do you know him and i said
no i've never heard of him
and then john invited me and ended up
offering me a five-year fellowship there
under one condition that i'll switch to
astrophysics
and then i said okay i cannot turn down
this this offer and
uh then there was after the five years
there was a
a faculty search at harvard university
and nobody wanted that position because
the chance of getting tenure
were quite small i mean the last person
to get tenure
in that department was like decades
earlier
and so i didn't worry about it because i
could always have
go back to the farm that was plan b
and actually farm life is not much worse
than
academia in fact it might be better in
some respects and
i was not nervous and i i accepted that
position
they first offered it to someone else
and he turned it down
and then i i accepted it and then they
gave me tenure three years later so um
at that point i said okay well i'm in an
arranged marriage here
but i'm actually married to my true love
because in
astrophysics we address philosophical
questions using the scientific method
uh and i ended up about 14 years later
sharing the astronomy department at
harvard and i've been the longest
serving chair for the past
nine years my term was extended twice
which was unprecedented
uh and you know it makes me very
different than my colleagues because
i was not intending to pursue this i had
interest in the broad picture in
philosophy
and you know i never regarded myself as
a typical nerd that got into math
and physics in order to specialize in a
very narrow niche
i mean what interests me is the bigger
picture
so i hear a lot of people who are
interested in philosophy a lot of people
in astrophysics specifically although
to tell you the truth i haven't talked
to many people in other areas of physics
but
a lot of people who end up in
astrophysics are also interested in
philosophy
so where where is that overlap
well it's interesting because the
universe is the biggest environment that
we can think of
so obviously you can live your life here
on earth
and just focus on matters that are close
to you
but that's similar to just saying i
don't want to hear about the news
in the world i just want the news of my
town
you know that's all i care about and of
course you know most of the time it will
be sufficient
to just focus on what happens around you
but every now and then you know if there
is a pandemic
and it comes from wuhan in china a place
that you've never heard of it will hit
you
and if you don't figure out why then you
might not take the
precautions necessary and knowing about
the bigger environment is important
in order for you to cope with reality
you want the maximum amount of
information about reality and
you know that's why i mean many people
say who cares about the sky
you know who cares about it we have our
own problems here on earth
well guess what 66 million years ago
there was a giant rock the size of the
island of manhattan
that became bigger and bigger on the sky
the dinosaurs looked up
and then the fun stopped when it hit the
ground and
three quarters of four life forms on
earth were wiped out
so you can pretty much behave like the
dinosaurs right and
you know eat grass all day and enjoy
your food
but when such a giant rock comes along
you know that will be the end of your
life
and so we need to know about where we
are
in my context you know my latest book
and my recent interest
is asking the question you know is there
a smarter kid
on our block
okay so that's what i want to talk to
you about because that is
absolutely fascinating so in your book
and correct my pronunciation but
um there's a there's an object
and is it
so it was spotted in hawaii and can you
describe
what that object was or potentially
could be
right so this was the first object that
was identified close to earth
that definitely came from outside the
solar system
we know that because it was moving too
fast to be bound to the sun
and it's sort of like finding
an object in your backyard that came
from the street
so it saves you the trouble of going to
the street and figuring out what's going
on there because
the object made its way to us so by
looking at it we can figure out what's
out there
we don't need to make the trip uh and
actually traveling to another star is a
very long journey
you know if we use the uh rockets that
we
are using nowadays to to
go to planets uh you know like the
perseverance rover that is about to land
today um then uh
it would take 50 000 years to reach the
nearest
star and you know we we should have sent
it when the first humans left africa for
it to arrive today
you know it's a long journey so it's
worthwhile looking at objects that just
arrived to our neighborhood
and of course the first assumption that
astronomers made was
it's probably a comet like comets we
have seen within the solar system most
of the rocks are
have ice on the surface so when they get
close to the sun it evaporates and you
get
this cometary tail the only problem was
it didn't look like a comet there was no
cometary tail and in fact the speeds of
space telescope looked very
deeply around it and couldn't find any
traces of dust or
or carbon-based molecules so definitely
not a comet
so then what is it well as it was
stumbling
uh it changed its brightness as a result
of reflecting
sunlight by a factor of 10 and what that
means is that
projected on the sky its area was
changing
by a factor of 10. so just imagine a
piece of paper tumbling in the wind
uh it you know it needs to have a very
extreme shape
uh and and the best fit to the variation
of the light
was that of a pancake shape not cigar
shape
so uh here you have a pancake shaped
object without cometary tail
and then on top of that you know this
this is the straw that broke the
comments
back as far as i'm concerned it
exhibited an extra
push away from the sun without a
cometary tail so there was no rocket
effect from gas evaporating from it
and the only thing the only sense i
could make of it was
it does it because it reflects sunlight
and actually just a few months ago in
september 2020
there was another object discovered by
the same telescope
pan stars in hawaii that
also had no cometary tail
and was pushed away from the sun by
reflecting sunlight
and turns out this one we can tell
uh was a rocket booster that was
launched in 1966
uh in a mission to the moon and we know
that we produced it it was hollow and
had a very thin surface and that's why
it had a lot of area for its weight
so that the reflection of sunlight was
sufficient to give it a push
in the case of a muammua you needed a
very thin object as well
uh sort of like a sail but not
necessarily yourself something thin
and nature doesn't make you know pancake
shaped
thin sales you know it doesn't make that
uh and so that led me to suggest that
tomoa may be artificial
and if so it brings the question who
made it
okay so i have a couple of questions
they're probably dumb but i'm going to
ask you anyway
so you said no dumb questions only dumb
answers go ahead
we'll see um so you said it was
reflective
now couldn't couldn't that have meant
that somewhere it melted
um well we know exactly what the surface
temperature was because we know the
trajectory relative to the sun
and the temperature to which an object
gets heated without any gas around it
is just dependent on its distance from
the sun okay
so we know that it was heated by
hundreds of degrees and
that's enough to melt uh water ice for
example definitely to make a cometary
tail but there was no comet retail so
if you have either rock or something
solid
then it shouldn't melt at those
temperatures it wasn't close enough to
the sun
to evaporate everything you know like um
so um the one thing we know about it is
we couldn't see any heat coming from it
with a splitter space telescope
and we know what temperature the surface
got to so
not seeing heat means that it's smaller
than a certain
size the area of this thing could not be
bigger and the size is roughly that of a
football field you know a few hundred
feet
um and it cannot be bigger than that
because otherwise we would see the
infrared radiation the emission from it
the heat
and if it were just 10 times smaller it
had to reflect all the sunlight that is
uh shining on it in order for us to see
what we saw you know the amount of light
that we saw so
so all together it's fairly reflective
you know in the high end of
of the objects that we usually see uh
it's
sort of um modestly shiny on the shiny
end of all the objects but
but not completely unprecedented in
terms of
objects we see in space okay so you said
it was
kind of pancake shaped so it couldn't
and it came how many objects have we
seen come from
outside of our oh this was the first one
and then there was a second one
uh discovered in 2019
called borisov after the russian amateur
astronomer that discovered it
uh gennady borisov and that one looked
just like a comment it had a commentary
tale the same way that we see
our comments and so people said to me
that one looks natural like doesn't it
convince you that
is also natural and by the way um is
scout in the hawaiian language that's
where the name came from
so i to that i replied
you know when you see a plastic bottle
on the beach that is full of
rocks that are naturally produced and
afterwards you
see a rock that doesn't make the plastic
bottle
a natural object you know the fact that
you see a rock after that
and another way to put it is you know
when i met my wife for the first time i
thought that she's special and unique
and i met a lot of women after that it
didn't change my opinion about my wife
so you know the two objects have nothing
to do with each other
okay so say this was so your your
your hypothesis your theory is that it
could have potentially been crafted
somewhere else
so that's fascinating
that's very interesting um do you have
any
like do you have any thoughts about why
it would have come in
yeah so that's a very interesting
question what was its purpose and why
and then you know we should look at the
clues of course i have no idea unless
you know
we collect more more evidence but
another peculiar fact about this object
is that it was
um at rest in the so-called local
standard of rest
which is the frame of reference that you
get to after you average the random
motions of all the stars in the vicinity
of the sun
it's sort of like the galactic parking
lot you know the
local frame of reference and the sun is
moving relative to that
just like any other star but um was at
rest in that frame
only one in 500 stars is so much at rest
as um
was uh in the local standard of rest and
it's sort of like seeing a beauty on the
surface of the ocean
and the solar system was like a giant
ship that bumping into that view and
giving it a kick
um and then the question is why why
would it be in that frame and
one possibility is that you have a grid
an array of such objects that
potentially
are used for navigation you know to know
your coordinates relative to that array
uh or maybe you know if it's
artificially made maybe it's used for
communication purposes for real
as a relay station and we just don't
know and i think
the way to proceed forward you know is
to look for more objects of the same
type
so when i go to the kitchen and i find
an ant
i usually get alarmed because it means
that there are many more ants
around and the same here you know after
a few years of looking at the sky with
pan stars
we found this one and so if you continue
to look for a few more years we'll find
another one
and the vera rubin observatory is a new
observatory
that will come online within less than
three years and
we it could potentially find one every
month and my point is that if we deploy
cameras
within the orbit of the earth around the
sun
one of the cameras may be close to a
future omuamualike object
and it could take a picture a photograph
and
you know they say that the picture is
worth a thousand words
in my case a picture is worth 66 000
words
the number of words in my book i
wouldn't need to write the book if we
had a picture
and that's really what i want okay
um i've got one more question about
about it being melted
could it have possibly been some sort of
object that was melted in a different
solar system and then
somehow
parked and then what our solar system
ran into it
or am i misunderstanding things uh yeah
no i mean if you are talking about the
natural are you talking about the
natural or
yeah i'm trying to pick holes in your
asteroids okay
right thank you so let me let me help
you in doing that okay so um
aside from it so i wrote this paper
suggesting an artificial origin
and the scientific community then
divides into three parts
there is a small contingency of
of people that are you know bloggers and
popular science writers and
they don't really practice science they
don't have a single paper over the past
decade that they wrote
and i don't really care what they say
you know that is
of no interest because they are not
practicing scientists you know
then you have the vast majority of the
astronomy community
these are people that never worked on
related subjects
and they just prefer not to get into
controversial debates so they say
you know it's probably a rock it's
probably natural uh business as usual
but then you have the people i really
respect the scientists that pay
attention to the anomalies to the
unusual properties of
and try to explain them as a natural
object and they suggested the following
i mean one proposal was that maybe
it's a hydrogen iceberg sort of a chunk
of frozen hydrogen
so that when it evaporates as a result
of the illumination by the
sunlight there is a cometary tail that
gives it this
push as a result of the rocket effect
but we can't see the hydrogen cometary
tail because it's transparent
the problem with that is hydrogen
in a hydrogen iceberg can very easily
get evaporated
so we wrote a paper showing that it
would not survive the journey such an
object could not really travel
across large interstellar distances
uh it would be evaporated by starlight
then there was another proposal that
maybe it's a cloud of dust
you know just like a dust bunny that you
find at home the size of a football
field
and the dust particles are very loosely
bound so it's very porous
and it's a hundred times less dense than
air and then
by reflecting sunlight it's so
lightweight it's sort of a fluffy cloud
of dust
that it gets pushed by reflecting
sunlight and the problem with that is
just what you suggested when
when it gets uh along the path of
when it gets closer to the sun it gets
heated by hundreds of degrees and i find
it hard to believe that such a cloud of
dust that is a hundred times less dense
than air
uh would uh have enough material
strength to hold together
if it's heated by hundreds of degrees
and then
maybe it's a shrapnel you know a piece
uh debris
from the disruption of a bigger object
by a star
you know when an object comes close to
assad just like you you were suggesting
maybe it melts it maybe the you know
produces
by the force of gravity the
gravitational tide makes some shrapnel
pieces uh the problem is that this would
produce usually elongated pieces
rather than pancake shape pieces um
and moreover the chance of coming close
to a star
is very small com i mean most objects
would be far from a star would not
suffer that
and why would you get the first object
to be a relic of that
uh so anyway um there are problems with
all three proposals that were put on the
table that's all that these are the
three alternatives that were suggested
and you just put them you know side by
side on the table and
next to them the artificial origin and
to me it looked more compelling
okay the artificial origin now you might
say okay it's a matter of taste
you know fine i have arguments against
those three and
i doubt that there are the explanation
but my point is
let's collect more evidence and the
reaction of the community is
it's never aliens extraordinary claims
require extraordinary evidence to which
i say
you know extraordinary
leads to extraordinary ignorance because
if you reject
upfront the artificial origin
possibility
you will never i mean what do they want
that i bring them an alien that will
shake their hand and only then they
would
be able to to discuss the subject i mean
that makes no sense
we have some anomalies we need to
explain them and we put all
possibilities that we can think of
on the table and then collect more
evidence i mean what else
and if we just assume it's a rock we
will never collect the evidence
it will resemble just like a caveman you
know a caveman presented with a cell
phone
would conclude the cell phone is a shiny
rock because that's what the caveman is
used to doing
so my point is we have to collect more
evidence
we have to take it seriously and in my
book i talk about omuamua's
wager you know similar to pascal's wager
pascal
bless pascal the french philosopher said
you know about
god he said you know there are two
possibilities either god
exists or not and if god exists the
implications are huge
so we must contemplate that possibility
discuss it because the implications are
huge
i say the same thing about omua being an
artificial object
the implications are huge for us so we
cannot dismiss we cannot brush it off
we should collect more evidence
yeah 100 i mean wasn't germ theory
wasn't that dismissed
before there was like evidence and that
had huge implications too
not recognizing the germs right no i
mean there are many examples in history
and i guess the most important among
them is
the idea that we are not at the center
of the universe you know
the the ancient greek philosopher
aristotle
argued we are at the center of the
universe of course it flatters our ego
to believe that and for a thousand years
people believe that and he had a
beautiful model where
there were spheres centered around us
and then
copernicus and galileo galilei argued no
the earth
is moving around the sun and what was
the response to that
the philosophers at the time said we
don't want to look through a telescope
we know the answer
the sun moves around the earth and they
put galileo in house arrest
now what did they accomplish they
maintained their ignorance
and you know the earth continued to move
around the sun so
reality really doesn't care whether we
ignore it
uh it's it's whatever it is and just
think about the bigger picture you know
imagine that we have relics of ancient
civilizations that
you know maybe dead by now you know
billions of years ago send spacecrafts
or other things into space and now these
things are passing near us and just look
at
earth from above and think oh all these
scientists are not even willing to
entertain that possibility and therefore
they're saying everything is rocks
and they're ridiculing avi that is just
suggesting
to check and you know does that make any
sense
i don't think so why should that you
know why shouldn't we check
the implications are huge for our uh
perception of our place in the universe
yeah definitely i think so i don't want
to be unprepared when aliens show up
exactly because oh you weren't a rock
too late um
but wouldn't you my assumption for if
there's any type of alien out there my
assumption would be that
if they end up coming to earth it's
probably not
out of a place of curiosity necessarily
and more of a
oh this seems like a habitable place and
you guys are kind of annoying
so if we end up with more evidence that
there's some sort of alien tech
what's what do you think the proper
response to that is is it
what do you do that's an excellent
question so let me first
say that most of the junk we'll find in
space is very old probably you know
billions of years because
the sun is a late camera most of the
stars formed before the sun
billions of years before the sun and so
if they had a history similar
to us um you know there were
civilizations that
existed billions of years ago and by now
they're they're not around anymore so
you know it's sort of like on earth
there were cultures that are not around
anymore like the mayan culture
we cannot have a fun conversation with
the mayans they're not around
the only thing we can do is uh find
relics that they left behind in
archaeological
sites and in the past you know we search
for civilizations
looking for radio signals but that's
equivalent to trying to have a phone
conversation you need the counterpart to
be
alive and if most civilizations are dead
by now
that's not a good approach so my
suggestion is simple let's do space
archaeology
let's look for relics floating in space
and
of course you know it's just like
getting a letter in the mail if the post
service is very slow
the person who sent it uh is not alive
anymore and that's okay
because you learn about the past history
and you can learn much more
and then or more maybe one of these
relics and
i think space archaeology should be a
mainstream activity you know it's
something that
we do just like archaeology on earth
you know in order to find about previous
uh cultures that may have existed
that's smart of course there should be
way more evidence of things in the past
than there are than there is of evidence
right now but
to answer to answer your other ques you
asked me what would be the proper
response if there is a contact with a
live civilization and
to that i would just say you know when
you enter a room full of strangers
um it's prudent not to speak first
just to listen because you never know
what risks might
be awaiting as you were pointing out you
know maybe there are some
um malicious intentions out there and
that
could harm us and so unfortunately we
were not careful you know we were not
very intelligent we
we were broadcasting for more than a
century now radio waves into space and
announcing our existence and if there is
anyone out there within 100 light years
with the radio telescope
who's making these decisions for the
rest of us
now it will take a while for uh for for
them to respond of course because of the
distances but
we will probably hear back at some point
that's horrifying
i i definitely did not sign up for that
okay okay thank you that was very
that was very interesting um where can
people find your book
where can people find you and more
information about this
so my book is in any store that any
outlet that
sells books such as amazon bars and
nobles anywhere
and on the first week of its appearance
it
was selected to the new york times
bestseller list between
michelle and barack obama and
number six and
about me i have a website at harvard
university so just
put my name in google avi loeb
and you will find more about my research
about my
commentaries in scientific american and
everything that you want to know about
me
that was fascinating thank you very much
for coming on
my pleasure thanks for inviting me
[Music]
you